die linksfraktion hat sich in einem
antrag mit einem zentralen immobilien
register beschäftigt und fordert diesen
einzuführen darum soll es in den
nächsten knapp 40 minuten gehen denn der
linksfraktion zufolge sind die
eigentumsverhältnisse auf den
immobilienmarkt in deutschland zu
intransparent das liegt unter anderem
der fraktion zufolge daran dass
immobilien noch mit bargeld bezahlt
werden können
und dass die erste rednerin dazu die
diesen antrag nun hier vorstellen wird
ist caren lay von der linksfraktion
frauen werden noch frauen live ist wo
sie anfangen bittet um ruhe im sorgen
dass wir jetzt die plätze einnehmen so
dass wir der debatte auch gut folgen
können
frau presse frau präsidentin meine sehr
verehrten damen und herren wenn ich
mafioso wäre würde ich in deutschland
investieren das sagt roberto scarpinato
ein mafia jäger aus palermo
ausgerechnet in deutschland wer hätte
das gedacht aber ja schätzungsweise 20
milliarden euro werden pro jahr in
deutschland alleine im immobiliensektor
gewaschen das ist schmutziges geld aus
waffenhandel schutzgelderpressung
drogenhandel und prostitution
deutschland gilt als paradies für
geldwäsche das darf nicht sein hier muss
endlich etwas geschehen
und das hängt eben ganz zentral damit
zusammen dass die eigentumsverhältnisse
im immobiliensektor in deutschland im
internationalen vergleich besonders
intransparent sind
das ist eines der gründe warum wir als
linke fordern endlich an zentralen
immobilie gäste einzurichten
und das ist sehr wohl ich das einzige
instrument gegen geldwäsche in der
vergangenen legislaturperiode hatte die
fraktion die linke auch die grünen viele
forderungen vorgelegt zurecht aber die
einrichtung eines zentralen
transparenten immobilo registers eben
die voraussetzung dafür dass wir die
anderen instrumente auch benutzen können
und deswegen muss es jetzt zu beginn der
legislaturperiode geschehen
als bildungspolitikerin weißig
luxemburgische briefkastenfirmen
anwaltskanzleien aus zypern geleitet
wird es von den kanalinseln bei allen
ist der deutsche immobilienmarkt sehr
beliebt und sie treiben einfach die
preise nach oben weil es ihnen möglich
ist deutlich mehr geld auf den tisch zu
legen hat zum beispiel eine vierköpfige
familie mit dem kleinen einkommen das
ist ungerecht und deswegen muss auch als
bildungspolitischer sicht endlich etwas
passieren
die bundesregierung wollte am ende der
letzten legislatur endlich etwas dagegen
tun hat es eigene forschungs institute
haben mit beauftragt aber sehen da
selbst die bundesregierung ihre
institute wissen gar nicht wegen dieses
land gehört
und deswegen muss man sich dann eben bei
kritischen journalistinnen und
journalisten darüber informieren wem die
städte eigentlich gehören das meine
damen und herren ist ein unhaltbarer
zustand
deutschland macht aus dem grundbuch ein
geheimnis wie die schweiz aus ihren
bankkonten wir brauchen endlich mehr
transparenz auf den immobilienmärkten
und
der dritte grund warum wir hier ein
zentrales immobilien ressort von am das
ist tatsächlich der aktuelle krieg in
der ukraine der ukraine und die
notwendigkeit schnell und zügig gezielte
sanktionen gegen russische oligarchen zu
verhängen aber schauen wir uns die
zahlen an wie sie dann im märz da waren
in belgien sind vermögen in höhe von
zehn milliarden euro eingefroren worden
in italien waren es mehrere hundert
millionen euro und in deutschland gerade
mal 95 millionen euro auch das kann
nicht sein wer in einem
völkerrechtswidrigen krieg verdient wer
sich am system putin bereichert dem soll
deutschland nicht als sicherer ort für
immobilien gelten
auch dafür brauchen wir ein zentrales
immobilien register das monopoly muss
endlich beendet werden
soweit caren lay die sprecherin für
mieten bau und wohnungspolitik der
linksfraktion anlässlich des antrags
dass ihre denen ihre fraktion hier
eingereicht hat und ob sie direkt
antworten geht jetzt sebastian fiedler
für die sozialdemokraten
vieles richtige ist gesagt worden was
den befund angeht ich will den versuchen
ein bisschen deutlicher orientierter
noch herauszustellen in der tat ist es
so aktuell dass es zahllose immobilien
in deutschland gebe denn wir aktuell
nicht wissen wer die wirtschaftlichen
eigentümer sind und das ist schlicht
unter gas und inakzeptabel und da
sollten uns hoffentlich auf alle einig
sein und er stelle
die grundlegenden zusammenhänge wenn ich
versuche noch ein bisschen breiter mal
aufzustellen denn es geht in der tat
zunächst einmal nach allen schätzungen
die wir so wissen so viele
untersuchungen gibt es dazu nicht um
etwa 100 milliarden euro die jedes jahr
hier kriminell erwirtschaftet und
potenziell gewaschen werden 100
milliarden da könnte es bei der einen
oder dem anderen her klingel exakt das
sondervermögen was wir beschlossen haben
es würde also ausreichen wenn es uns ein
jahr lang gelänge alle kriminellen
erlöse einzuziehen dann könnten wir uns
in debatten über die ganze bundeswehr
jetzt gerade sparen um sozusagen die
themen mal miteinander in der dimension
ins verhältnis zu setzen
dabei geht es dabei geht es um handfeste
drogenkriminalität rauschgift aber
darüber rauschgiftkriminalität nicht nur
um rauschgift wie aus den enkel jets
wissen geht es darum im ort aufträge
folter es geht um waffen auch
kriegswaffen die dort gehandelt werden
es geht um tonnen von rauschgift es geht
um große kriminalitätsfelder wie
produkt- und markenpiraterie ist wird
gefälscht vom airbag bis zur kettensäge
es geht um ein riesengroßes
kriminalitätsphänomen der
umweltkriminalität das drittgrößte es
geht um menschenhandel zur ausbeutung
der sexuellen arbeitskraft oder der
arbeitskraft es geht um betrug um cyber
kriminalität ergänzen sie selbst denn
etwa zwei drittel der kriminalität wird
nur deswegen begangen weil es die täter
auf eigentum oder vermögen ihrer opfer
abgesehen haben und der entscheidende
zusammenhang ist dass die
ermittlungsbehörden bisher nur ein
prozent maximal dieser vermögen wort zu
gesicht bekommen und und das ist der
entscheidende zusammenhang transparency
sagt dass es eine studie 15 bis 30
prozent dieser erlöse landen in
immobilien das ist der eine begründung
zusammenhang warum wir uns intensiv um
diese frage kümmern müssen und der
zweite ist richtig aufgemacht in der tat
geht es natürlich um die sanktionen und
die frage wie gut wie sie durchsetzen
könnten und dazu liegen uns ehrlich
gesagt seit vielen jahren schon gute
erkenntnisse vor welche rolle hier
russische vermögenswerte denn so spielen
es hat einen sonderausschuss im
europäischen parlament der krim
ausschuss gegeben der sich mit
organisiertem verbrechen korruption und
geldwäsche beschäftigt habe der text
drei ausschuss insbesondere wirklich
handfeste befunden dort zutage geliefert
es gibt in teilen anekdotische evidenz
aus dem freistaat bayern da hat es 2013
mal den verkauf von finanz minister
söder von
33.000 wohnungen gegeben mit 85.000
mieterinnen und mietern da wusste man
auch nicht eigentlich die mieter wusste
nicht wem tatsächlich ihre wohnung
gehört und im umfeld dessen gab es
geldwäsche verdachtsmeldungen die
einschläge russische bekannte leute
enthielten am ende ermittelte allerdings
niemals obwohl es die
ermittlungsbehörden eigentlich wollten
und das alles müsste tatsächlich nicht
sein wenn wir uns mit dem rad aus der
fachwelt intensiver befassen würden und
transparenz herstellen war transparenz
einerseits den ermittlungsbehörden auch
bei den aktuellen sanktionen helfen
würde und auf der anderen seite weil er
der größte feind der geldwäscher ist
allerdings und da reißt ihr antrag so
ein bisschen ab an der stelle sind wir
in den debatten tatsächlich schon drei
meter weiter weil es auf der einen seite
erstens sind wie inter weiter weil sich
die task force mit diesen fragen
beschäftigt und auf der anderen seite
haben wir auf europäischer ebene schon
debatten darüber dass wir uns in der
zielsetzung jedenfalls auf den weg
machen müssen um die verschiedenen
register lösungen die es geht
miteinander zu verknüpfen das stichwort
lautet was wir eigentlich brauchen und
das recht aus der perspektive der
ermittlerinnen und ermittler sind
vermögens register das heißt wir müssen
in der zielsetzung uns darüber einig
werden dass wir ein besseres transparenz
register benötigen hier das die auf
europäischer ebene miteinander vernetzt
werden müssen wir müssen uns darüber
einigen dass wir in der tat zentral
abfragbar hre immobilien register
benötigen und die konten abruf
informationen mindestens diese drei
bausteine gehören zueinander und das
[Applaus]
und das sind nicht nur die einzigen
bausteine ich freue mich darüber dass
die spd-fraktion glaube ich die einzige
fraktion ist die sich hier ausschuss
übergreifend mit diesen fragen jetzt
schon seit februar befasst denn wir
gucken breiter tatsächlich auf die
fragen die mit schmutzigem geld zu tun
haben nicht nur aus dem aus der
perspektive transparenz sondern durchaus
es gibt die ganz guten legislativen
vorschlag gerade von drei klugen
professoren die sagen wie gehen wir
eigentlich in deutschland mit
verdächtigen vermögenswerten um und
sagen es gibt bestimmte kriterien die
der rechtsstaat hier definieren kann
weil nämlich schmutziges geld eine
gefahr für unsere rechtsordnung ist weil
eigentlich die eigentumsgarantie hier
nicht gelten darf und die sagen wenn wir
bestimmte kriterien für schmutziges geld
und schmutziges vermögen haben ab einer
bestimmten größenordnung muss der staat
einen auskunftsanspruch generieren
können um dann zu sagen wenn der nicht
befriedigt wird dann zieht der staat
dieses vermögen ein das ist eine debatte
die wir zumindest in der fraktion gerade
aktuell führen von der ich mir wünschen
dass wir hier auch bereiter
voranschreiten denn die gesamte
geldwäsche debatte
applaus von der fraktion der linken
immerhin also dass wir ich weiß ja nicht
was gut oder schlecht finden soll in der
tat
aber der entscheidende punkt ist und da
sollten wir uns alle einig sein wir
haben wir müssen diese ganzen
anonymisierungs strategien tatsächlich
aufhellen und deswegen ist transparenz
ein kernelement was ermittlerinnen und
ermittlern nicht nur bei sanktionen
sondern auch bei schmutzige geld bei
parteifinanzierung wenn ich mir manche
richtung gucken darf durchaus sehr viel
helfen würde und wir dort viel mehr
erkenntnisse hätten das schon als in der
vergangenheit also diskutieren sind das
mit uns so wie wir das in der fraktion
jetzt schon versuchen voranzutreiben
herzlichen dank für die hornisse
sebastian fiedler gab es für die spd
fraktion auch transpareny international
hand die unter anderen einen immobilien
register gefordert um geldwäsche zu
bekämpfen matthias hauer jetzt für die
unionsfraktion
damen und herren wir beraten einen
antrag der fraktion die linke sie
fordert ein zentrales immobilien
register die forderung kommen uns recht
bekannt vor sie haben ja schon mal
versucht rot rot grün in berlin über den
bundesrat da sind sie gescheitert jetzt
versuchen sie das nochmal aufzuwärmen
hier über den bundestag sie haben den
antrag etwas ergänzt das will ich ihnen
zugute halten zwei sätze zu ihrem
lieblingsthema enteignungen sie haben
auch die begründung ein bisschen
angepasst den
aktuellen der aktuellen politischen
großwetterlage und jetzt soll ein
zentrales immobilien register plötzlich
auch deshalb eingeführt werden um besser
gegen russische oligarchen vorgehen zu
können
ausgerechnet die linke will nun putins
freundin an den kragen das glauben sie
doch selbst nicht linksradikale und
rechtsradikaler in diesem hohen haus
sind vielmehr seit jahren putins
propaganda schleuder hier im deutschen
bundestag
und prominent
prominente vertreter von der fraktion
die linke hatten bis zuletzt den
russischen truppenaufmarsch an der
grenze zur ukraine verteidigt sie haben
täter opfer umkehr betrieben sie haben
verschwörungstheorien über den
russischen mordanschlag auf den
oppositionellen navalny verbreitet sie
haben unsere bundeswehr verächtlich
gemacht sie haben unserem
verteidigungsbündnis nato
kriegstreiberei unterstellt sie haben
deutschen medien vorgeworfen
lügenmärchen des us geheimdienstes zu
verbreiten und sie haben die
berechtigten sorgen unserer
osteuropäischen nachbarn kleingeredet es
ist grotesk dass ausgerechnet sie uns
weismachen wollen mit ihren immobilien
register russischen oligarchen ans leder
zu wollen
und
auf wessen seite sie tatsächlich stehen
das erfahrende immer wieder nachdem
russland die krim überfallen hat und
nachdem separatisten im dornbusch durch
die russische durch russland aufgerüstet
wurden reisten sogar abgeordnete ihrer
fraktion zu diesen warlords in die ost
ukraine und machten mit ihnen propaganda
fotos noch am sonntag vor dem einmarsch
im februar hatte die
fraktionskollegin wagt nicht aus der
fraktion die linke in einer talkshow
wörtlich gesagt wir können heilfroh sein
dass putin nicht so ist wie er
dargestellt wird ein durchgeknallter
nationalist der sich berauscht grenzen
zu verschieben zitat ende doch fragt wer
diese darstellung ist exakt richtig und
es war auch damals nicht das erste mal
dass putin grenzen verschoben hat dies
alles steht exemplarisch dafür wie die
linke putins russland absichtlich
verklärt hat und das schlimmste ist sie
haben aus ihren fehlern nicht gelernt
indem sie der ukraine noch immer
lebensnotwendige hilfe versagen wollen
kein einziger abgeordneter fraktion hat
gestern dem gemeinsamen antrag von
ampel-koalition und union zugestimmt die
der ukraine umfassende hilfe zukommen
lassen wollten erst gestern hat ihre
obfrau im auswärtigen ausschuss frau
daten nennen diese hilfe für die ukraine
als zitat faktischen kriegseintritt
bezeichnet ampel und union als kriegs
kriegskoalition tituliert und zum
widerstand aufgerufen sie betreiben
angstmacherei und putin propaganda in
reinform allein
allein coatings riesen entscheidet
darüber wer russlands zur kriegspartei
macht wenn russland die waffen
niederlegt endet der krieg wenn die
ukraine die waffen niederlegt gibt es
kein ukraine mehr und putin wird sich
neue opfer suchen und das dürfen wir
nicht zulassen
und natürlich müssen wir sanktionen
gegen russische oligarchen besser
durchsetzen aber dafür braucht niemand
tipps der linken denn sie sind teils
problem die sind kein teil der lösung
wir haben in den letzten jahren
umfangreiche maßnahmen zur bekämpfung
von geldwäsche im immobiliensektor auf
den weg gebracht wir sehen aktuell dass
viele eu partner deutlich erfolgreicher
als deutschland mal agieren was das
einfrieren von vermögenswerten der
profiteure des systems putin angeht die
bundesregierung hat angekündigt dass sie
ein so genanntes sanktions durchsetzungs
gesetz prüfe es dürfte konsens sein dass
erhebliche schwachstellen bei der
durchsetzung der sanktionen gibt die
prüfung sollte nun endlich in einen
konkreten gesetzentwurf münchen wir als
union werden das konstruktiv begleiten
ein solches sanktions durchsetzungs
gesetz wir können auch über die
grundlegende reform ist rund buch lesen
sprechen wenn die reform durchdachtes
und zur effektiven durchsetzung auch
dieser sanktionen notwendig ist wir
wollen nämlich keine bürokratischen
doppelstrukturen wir wollen dass der
datenschutz gewährleistet bleibt wir
wollen dass unbescholtene
immobilienbesitzer nicht dadurch in den
fokus von kriminellen geraten können und
wir wollen dass die maßnahmen
zielgerichtet und hart die treusten
unterstützer des kriminellen putin
regimes treffen das gewährleistet der
antrag der linken nicht deshalb lehnen
wir ihn ab vielen dank für die
aufmerksamkeit
matthias hauer hat hier den antrag des
landes berlin
das land berlin hatte in einem
vergangenen jahr im bundesrat einen
antrag zu einem immobilien register
eingereicht er wurde abgelehnt und aus
dem land berlin kommt die nächste
rednerin hanna steinmüller von den
bündnisgrünen
liebe kolleginnen und kollegen lieber
hauer in der schule hätte man gesagt
thema verfehlt eigentlich steht in den
top um das zentrale in registern nicht
ohne visionen rief partei
auch unwichtig wollten sie nichts zum
zentralen immobilien register sagen
offensichtlich haben sie auch in den
letzten 16 jahren nichts dazu getan das
belastet die mieterinnen und mieter in
diesem land und darum geht es eigentlich
in dieser debatte
deutschland ist ein geldregen paradies
das wissen wir das hat aber auch
ministerin geiwitz beim auftakt vom
bündnis für bezahlbares wohnen am
mittwoch noch einmal bekräftigt und das
ist ein problem
es wir haben keinen überblick wem in
deutschland die immobilien gehören es
fehlt uns die transparenz profi kicker
hat schon auf die zur übung geht mir
dieser kids
hatten auch die verbrechen hingewiesen
die zur geldwäsche fühlen aber ich bin
wohnungs politikerin deswegen möchte ich
meinen blick auf die mieterinnen und
mieter wenden was bedeuten geldwäsche
und intransparenz auf den mieten markt
sie beizeiten für die mieterinnen dass
der verfügbare bestand reduziert wird
geldwäscher kauf mit viel geld objekte
in guten lagen also gerade da wo
wohnraum knapp ist familie in berlin
mitte ist das ein sehr häufiges phänomen
die menschen können liebling in der
bürgersprechstunde beschweren sich
menschen bei mir dass sie keine wohnung
finden ard so viel leer steht dass es
auch eine folge der intransparenz auf
dem wohnungsmarkt und da müssen wir ran
die zweite folge ist geldwäsche und ins
transparenz führen zu treiben steigenden
preisen die geldwäsche auf mit
immobilienmarkt in deutschland trägt
dazu bei dass sich die preisspirale
weiter dreht weil geldwäscher in 22 auf
viel höhere preise bereit sind zu zahlen
weil es eben nicht darum geht eine
wohnung zu vermieten damit die sie zu
bewirtschaften sondern einfach nur darum
geht das geld zu parken deswegen würden
diese käufe preistreibend und ehrliche
käuferinnen und käufer zahlen damit
drauf damit zerstört geldwäsche
immobiliensektor die ziele von
bezahlbarem wohnraum
liebe kolleginnen und kollegen die gute
nachricht als aber sie kennen das
koalition das problem und werden es
angehen wir haben uns darauf eigentlich
dass wir die illegale finanzierung von
immobilien durch geeignete maßnahmen
bekämpfen wollen wir werden die
datentransparenz den ist es besser dass
daten wagen grundbuch mit dem
transparenz register verknüpfen den
erwerb von immobilien mit bargeld ich
finde es unfassbar dass es nach wie vor
möglich ist endlich verbieten und einen
sachkundenachweis für maklerin
einführten das alles
das alles tut um mehr transparenz auf
dem immobilienmarkt wir werden uns im
ausschuss weiter mit dem thema befassen
wir haben viel zu tun und freue mich
darauf dass wir es in bewegung kommt
vielen dank
[Applaus]
fabian jacobi auf die fraktion ist der
nächste redner des bank
[Applaus]
ja
präsidentin meine damen und herren wenn
wie das gestern der fall war wir von der
afg einmal in dem selben sinne abstimmen
wie die fraktion am entgegengesetzten
ende des hauses also die linkspartei
dann wird von manchen gern die
sogenannte hufeisen theorie bemüht also
die behauptung obwohl an
gegenüberliegenden seiten angesiedelt
sein wir und die kommunisten uns
irgendwie doch ganz nahe insofern ist es
passend wenn heute ein antrag der
linksfraktion behandelt wird der recht
augenfällig die absurdität dieser
theorie aufzeigt was will dieser antrag
ein zentrales immobilien register in dem
private lebensverhältnisse in bezug auf
grundstücke gesellschaftlich transparent
gemacht werden solle
ein nachdenklicher mensch hat einmal
angemerkt in primitiven standes
gesellschaften gebe es keine
privatsphäre der stammesangehörige lebe
sein leben unter den augen und damit
unter der dauernden kontrolle der
dorfgemeinschaft der grad der
zivilisiertheit einer gesellschaft
lassen sich demgemäß recht gut danach
bemessen inwieweit sie individualität
also die absonderung des einzelnen vom
kollektiv ermöglicht und zu lassen so
erschließt sich auch dass der
kommunismus der den menschen wesentlich
als funktionselemente des kollektivs
begreift eben nicht das endprodukt eines
gesellschaftlichen fortschritt darstellt
sondern im gegenteil eine rückkehr in
vor zivilisatorische zustände nur auf
einer höheren ebene
diese grundsätzliche einordnung sollte
man sich zunächst vor augen führen durch
wo man die einzelheiten eines solchen
antrags behandelt womit wird der linke
ruf nach einer ausweitung des zwangs zur
offenbarung die wetterverhältnisse
begründet die bekämpfung der geldwäsche
soll das ansinnen legitimieren an dem
zweck ist an sich wenig auszusetzen
selbstverständlich kann das recht auf
privatheit nicht absolut gesetzt werden
gibt es legitime interessen der
allgemeinheit die eingriffe
rechtfertigen können auch in hier
betroffenen bereich des grundstücks
verkehrs gibt es missbräuchliches und
auch kriminelles verhalten das eine oder
andere habe ich im rahmen meiner
berufstätigkeit miterlebt was übel
aufstößt ist die bedenkenlosigkeit mit
der die linke das unterbinden von in
teilbereichen vorhandenen missständen zu
einem flächendeckenden angriff auf die
privatsphäre ausnutzen will der antrag
ist
schlicht gehalten es gibt zum bereich
der staatlichen erfassung speicherung
weitergabe und auswertung von daten
durchaus eine rechtliche entwicklung
auch der verfassungs rechts sprechen die
anlass sein müsste den plan eines
solchen zentralregisters daraufhin zu
untersuchen ob das in dieser form
überhaupt zulässig ist der vorliegende
antrag lässt nicht erkennen dass die
verfasser hier ein problembewusstsein
hatcher sie verweisen darauf dass
ähnliches bereits im vergangenen jahr
durch die links regierung des landes
berlin im bundesrat eingebracht wurde
was sie nicht dazu sagen ist dass der
bundesrat den antrag abgelehnt hat
nachdem sich der rechtsausschuss des
bundesrates dagegen ausgesprochen hatte
er wird seine gründe gehabt haben
den antrag
im bundesrat zur einführung eines
zentralregisters hat die linksfraktion
hier im hause aber nicht einfach
übernommen ein mann war kreativ und hat
noch einen zweiten punkt hinzugefügt
kurz gesagt handelt es sich um die
summarische enteignung von grundstücken
deren eigentümer die angestrebte
offenlegung in dem register verweigern
dieser zweite aspekt des antrags ist zu
abstrus um darauf näher einzugehen die
verfassungswidrigkeit steht ihm in
leuchtbuchstaben auf die stirn
geschrieben
insgesamt handelt es sich bei diesem
antrag nach inhalt und niveau um
linkspopulistischen klamauk die
antragsteller verweisen darauf dass die
regierungsfraktion der spd und der
grünen ebenfalls die einrichtung eines
solchen zentralregisters fordern man
muss also befürchten dass uns im laufe
der legislatur auch noch ein
gesetzentwurf der bundesregierung
erhalte aber vielleicht ist der dann ja
von der fachlichen qualität um eine
vertiefte auseinandersetzung zu
verdienen
der überweisung dieses antrags in den
rechtsausschuss stimmen dazu auch wenn
das eigentlich nicht verdient vielen
dank
[Applaus]
fabian jacoby war das für die fw
fraktion auf ihn folgten und thorsten
lieb mitglied im rechtsausschuss und
mitglied der fdp-fraktion
kolleginnen und kollegen geehrte frau
kollegin mey ihre einbringung trainer
hat mir deutlich besser gefallen als der
antrag weil die analyse wie sie
formuliert haben ist ja wichtig ist
besteht handlungsbedarf nur kommt dass
in diesem antrag dazu gleich mehr so
nicht zum ausdruck der antrag den die
linksfraktionen hier stellt ist einer
von mehreren in dieser woche nach dem
motto und täglich grüßt das murmeltier
haben wir alles schon mal gehört habe
schon den eindruck wenn ihnen nichts
mehr einfällt wird irgendwelche
bürokratie gefordert werden neue
register gefordert oder wie in diesem
antrag an zweiter stelle wird
enteignungs fantasien nachgegangen
natürlich ist es selbstverständlich dass
handlungsbedarf besteht dass der
geldwäsche effektiv und wirksam bekämpft
werden muss wie man allerdings auf die
idee kommt dass man ausgerechnet mit dem
immobilien register mit dem zentralen
das effektiv bekämpft entschuldigung das
erklärt sich ehrlicherweise nicht das
register marke einen gewissen
voyeurismus dienen geldwäschebekämpfung
definitiv nicht effektiv
mit den vorschlag ein zentrales
immobilien register einzuführen setzen
sie vielmehr die eigentümerin eigentümer
unter generalverdacht der geldwäsche und
der kriminalität das ist gelinde gesagt
natürlich absurd eine beleidigung
derjenigen die in immobilien investieren
liebe kolleginnen und kollegen das
ist nicht offensichtlich ja auch um ein
schaufensterantrag handel sieht man
schon daran dass sie ja noch nicht mal
die gesamte begründung des abgelehnten
bundesratsantrag stellen sondern nur
auszugsweise das rausziehen aber eine
frage habe ich mir schon gestellt sie
zitieren in dem antrag den financial
secrecy index zur begründung warum
deutschland an geldwäsche paradies gibt
man kann über das thema reden das ist ja
von kollegen fiedler auch ganz zu recht
sehr breit deswegen muss ich das nicht
wiederholen angesprochen worden aber
haben sie da mal im einzelnen
reingeguckt was diesen wert 3
weiß ich jetzt ich kann ich nicht
beantworten aber die kernfrage um die es
hier im antrag geht nämlich die frage
welche daten sind öffentlich transparent
und zugänglich die tragen das ergebnis
jedenfalls nicht denn das ist weitgehend
weltweit standard das so zu handhaben
wie wir das in deutschland machen
deswegen reden sie an der sache vorbei
wenn sie ausgerechnet mit diesem
argument versuchen ihr register zu
bekunden
viele fragen bleiben nach dem antrag
offen wie verhält sich eigentlich die
forderung nach den immobilien register
im vergleich zum datenbank grundbuch das
sind zulauf ist es leider viel zu lange
dauert das neben digitalisierungs thema
wollen sie wirklich ein weiteres
register daneben dazu haben sie nichts
gesagt und nichts geschrieben
und was mich am meisten verblüfft hat
meint sie das wirklich ernst dazwischen
der begründung kein wort gesagt worden
dass sie wenn auskünfte nicht erteilt
werden enteignungs fordern was ist denn
das liebe kollege kollegen für ein
verständnis vom rechtsstaat ich glaube
das muss noch ein bisschen geübt werden
im lager der linksfraktion da
aber an bemerkenswerten ist das offenbar
bei ihnen bei der antragstellenden
fraktionen noch gar nicht angekommen ist
dass die koalition längst eine weitere
stufe bei der effektiven bekämpfung von
geldwäsche gezündet hat den
koalitionsvertrag empfehle ich zu lesen
an dieser stelle deswegen bin ich
dankbar für den angreifer genau die
mögliche renz register um richtigerweise
der verschleierung der wahren eigentümer
von immobilien zu beenden wir verehrte
damen und herren effiziente nutzung der
vorhandenen und aufbau befindlichen
strukturen stadt schaffen neuer
bürokratie das ist die devise der
koalition und da werden wir weiter daran
arbeiten wir fordern ein versteuerung
nachweis für gewerbliche immobilien
verkäufe aus dem ausland drittens das
verbot des erwerbs von immobilien
bargeld das sind echte handlungen und
nicht die einführung eines weiteren
registers auf eu-ebene und da gehört
dieses thema richtigerweise hin weil
natürlich macht gilt welche nicht vor
landesgrenzen
das ist ein gemeinsames europäisches
thema deswegen setze ich diese koalition
dafür ein dass die zentralen geldwäsche
vorschriften endlich in eine verordnung
in unmittelbar geltendes recht umgesetzt
werden damit die organisierte
kriminalität effektiv europaweit
bekämpfen liebe freundinnen freunde
fünfter und letztens dazu braucht es
natürlich auch eine effiziente behörde
ristic unterstützt die deutsche
bundesregierung
nachhaltig den von der kommission
vorgeschlagene einsetzung einer anti
geldwäsche behörde an dieser stelle und
weil wir das besonders ernst nehmen als
koalition als bundesregierung wollen wir
dass diese behörde nach deutschland
kommt nach frankfurt am main und ich
hoffe das tragen wir alle gemeinsam mit
ihr in diesem hause
sehr geehrte damen und herren sowie
gerade formuliert effektiv und wirksame
geldwäschebekämpfung jahr 2022 aus
digital europäisch vernetzt ohne
zusätzliche bürokratie monster und ohne
eigentümerin und eigentümer von
immobilien ein generalverdacht zu
unterwerfen deswegen nehmen wir den
antrag ab vielen dank
[Applaus]
die kollegin susanne hill hat das wort
für die cdu csu fraktion
[Applaus]
sehr geehrte frau präsidentin liebe
kolleginnen und kollegen im heutigen
antrag das haben wir schon gehört geht
es im kern um die bekämpfung der
geldwäsche insbesondere durch den kauf
von immobilien so zumindest habe ich den
antrag verstanden nach
expertenschätzungen sind 20 milliarden
euro die gewaschen werden in diesem
bereich jährlich das geld kommt aus
kriminellen geschäften wird in
immobilien investiert und so dem
wirtschaftskreislauf zugeführt
als grund wird angeführt dass die
herkunft der mittel und die
eigentumsverhältnisse nicht erkennbar
sind und man auch viel verschleiern kann
und im grundbuch gibt es auch keine
informationen dazu also muss als lösung
das zentrale immobilien register her
welche sämtliche informationen zu den
eigentümern enthalten und offenlegen
soll der vorliegende antrag ist auch
nach den eigenen angaben angelehnt an
den antrag des landes berlin aus dem
jahr 20 21 er wurde damals abgelehnt im
bundesrat jetzt wird er wenn auch in
leicht modifizierter form in den
bundestag eingebracht ich kann ihnen nur
sagen dadurch dass sie die 100 mal
wiederholen und mehrfach versuchen ein
zu probieren werden sie weder besser
noch wichtiger
ich lasse außerdem einmal außer acht
dass sie den antrag einfach abgekupfert
haben aber bedenklich finde ich die
forderung in der nummer zwei
dass sie wenn die informationen nicht so
fließen wie es gefordert ist eine
enteignung vorsehen und bei allem
respekt das ist ein generalverdacht
gegen alle die immobilien besitzen
sicherlich
gibt es gute gründe für die forderung
nach einem immobilien register vor allem
zur zeit bei ihr scheinbar und schwerte
und die sanktionen gegen die russischen
oligarchen durchzusetzen und ich möchte
ihnen sagen das geht erst es nicht von
heute auf morgen und zweitens muss es
gut vorbereitet sein und außerdem ist
schon viel passiert wir haben 2017 dass
transparenz register eingeführt und zu
einem voll register weiterentwickelt für
bestimmte fälle die bezug zu deutschland
aufweisen müssen die berichte
wirtschaftlich berechtigten ermittelt
und offengelegt werden müssen hier muss
aber zunächst nachgebessert werden wenn
wir über andere dinge nachdenken denn
fragt man die menschen in der praxis die
damit arbeiten ist die datenqualität des
transparents registers einfach schlecht
ein großteil der daten ist nicht zu
gebrauchen und die unstimmigkeit
meldungen die ankommen sind kaum mehr zu
bewältigen
liegt vor allem daran dass die angaben
zu den ausländischen firmen nicht passen
und das sind ja genau die die wir finden
wollen weil die diese unter sichten
konstrukte von
wieso ist die datenqualität auch noch so
schlecht die formulare sind einfach zu
kompliziert
und wir haben auch keine schnittstellen
und herr kollege fiedler wenn sie von
der digitalisierung sprechen
dann ist es so wenn wir keine
schnittstellen haben brauchen wir uns
über alles andere nicht unterhalten oder
wenn daten da sind kann ich sie nicht
übertragen also muss ich sie nochmal
generieren das hört los zu frust und wir
haben auch bisher keine folgen abschnitt
so der ziele ob sie sich überhaupt
erreichen lassen mit diesem register
wenn sie ansprechen 100 milliarden das
ist genau das was wir erwirtschaften
könnten dann möchte ich doch zu bedenken
geben auch die einrichtung wird geld
kosten die 100 milliarden werden sie
nicht sofort erzielen
liebe kolleginnen und kollegen wir
sprechen immer von entbürokratisierung
mit dem antrag den sie bringen schaffen
sie ein bürokratisches monster und das
passt einfach nicht zusammen wir dürfen
nicht prozesse doppeln wir sollen sie ja
vereinfachen
aus meiner erfahrung
beruflich kann ich sagen es trifft meist
die falschen wenn wir solche monster
schaffen die bürgerinnen und bürger und
unternehmer die sich friedlich verhalten
es trifft nicht die die sich mittels
männer bedienen oder komischer
konstrukte die bleiben zum schluss
verschont gut gemeint ist leider nicht
gut gemacht
zum abschluss noch sie weisen darauf hin
in ihrem antrag sie möchten die dinge
offen legen unter verweis auf 12
grundbuch ordnung in analogie das heißt
wenn jemand ein berechtigtes interesse
darlegt dann soll er einsicht ins
register erhalten ich glaube dieser
schutz reicht nicht aus rufen sie mal
beim grundbuchamt an und schauen sie wie
schnell sie informationen bekommen nicht
klappt so kann man das nicht machen der
antrag ist daher abzulehnen spanischen
[Applaus]
der kollege bernhard das wort für die
spd-fraktion
[Applaus]
frau präsidentin liebe kolleginnen und
kollegen
will zunächst mal sagen ja aber wir
diskutieren kritisch miteinander rede
hat sich heute den eindruck sie sind bei
der russland aussprache irgendwie nicht
rangekommen
und dann haben wir sozusagen ein
bisschen doch doch ich habe das aber ist
okay also ich fand es ehrlich gesagt ich
weiß ehrlich gesagt nicht was das thema
angeht ein bisschen wenig ich bin den
linken ehrlich gesagt ganz dankbar dafür
dass wir
dass wir das thema das wir das thema
nochmal erneut aufgreifen auch wenn man
eben der sache und im detail da gar
nicht zustimmen muss ich glaube aber
trotzdem dass es wichtig ist ich bin
nämlich sebastian fiedler sehr dankbar
dafür dass er einmal deutlich gemacht
hat werden sie nicht unverschämt ich
mache meine arbeit da können sie sicher
sein wären sie nicht ums geschäft ich
bin im kollegen fiedler sehr dankbar
dass er den kontext und den zusammenhang
sozusagen hierzu kriminalität und
immobilien die es geben kann dargestellt
hat und welches gefährdungspotenzial da
ist und wenn sie mal richtig überlegen
dann glaube ich ist mehr transparenz ein
element zum schutz von
immobilienwirtschaft und nicht die
fortschreibung des latenten verdachtes
darüber etwas schieflaufen es ist genau
umgekehrt wie sie sagen wir haben uns ja
öfter damit beschäftigt und die frage
müssen wir beantworten ist deutschland
eigentlich in orth vom geldwäsche und
gerade im immobiliensektor und ich finde
es auch wirklich nicht ungewöhnlich dass
wenn jemand sozusagen eine immobilie in
größerem umfang kaufte er sich nicht
hinter einer briefkastenfirma verstecken
darf ich finde es nicht ungewöhnlich
wenn mieterinnen und mieter einfach mal
wissen wollen wen eigentlich das haus
gehört in dem sie leben was ist denn
daran ehrlich gesagt das problem und da
ist transparenz doch eine antwort ist
eine herausforderung ja aber auch
konsequenzen gezogen ich will das sagen
im koalitionsvertrag drei verabredungen
der immobilienkauf mit bargeld wird
verboten ausländische käufer von
immobilien müssen als steuerungs
nachweis bringen in der zukunft und
außerdem sollen die grundbücher
transparenter werden und der doktor
liefert einige perspektiven aufgezeigt
das ist glaube ich gut so und wir haben
auch in der vergangenheit etwas mit
einer auch gemeinsam ich will das sagen
wir haben das verschärfte geld versteht
ist verpflichtet makler verpflichtet
sich sozusagen zu offenbaren wenn es im
kampf gegen kriminelle strukturen wenn
es die offenzulegen gilt gibt und
ähnliche dinge mehr das ist ein teil
dargestellt worden aber dennoch die
verschleierung auf dem immobilienmarkt
müssen wir meiner meinung nach beherzter
stoppen wenn die schätzungen mit den 100
milliarden und frau hat das auch
dargestellt wenn sie ausreichen denn das
transparenz register alleine ist nicht
hinreichend wirksam das ist dargestellt
worden ich empfehle ihnen mal den ein
oder anderen bericht der deutschen welle
von gestern dann können sie das am
berliner beispiel ganz deutlich sehen
und über all diese themen haben wir
schon gesprochen vor dem ukraine krieg
und wir müssen jetzt erkennen dass die
zeitenwende hauer dass die zeiten werden
da auch auf diesem sektor auf dem
immobiliensektor verschärft durch den
krieg durchschlägt denn trotz der
sanktionen gegen russland werden
offenbar in deutschland ja kaum
oligarchen immobilien beschlagnahmt und
das hat mit der fehlenden wissen auch
über immobilien und eigentümer etwas zu
tun
christian lindner hat in der debatte um
die zeitenwende eine fundamentale wende
vollzogen wie ich sehr respektiere er
sprach bei den erneuerbaren energien
davon dass das jetzt freiheits energien
seien freiheits energien sein
und ich muss sagen dass wir ihn
wahrscheinlich vorher nicht über die
lippen gekommen ich finde das mutig und
ähnliches sollte uns im kampf gegen die
geldwäsche gegen steuerhinterziehung
gegen verschleierung auch möglich sein
zentrale register sind uns doch gar
nicht unbekannt und fremd wir reden über
transparenz register wir reden über
lobbyregister die union nicht immer wert
auf dem krieg ist es ja sie wollen
register bei der zuwanderung haben ich
habe übrigens gar nichts dagegen aber
warum fordern wir das was für den
einzelnen auch im immobilienbereich
eigentlich einfach aber für den staat
sozusagen besonders wichtig ist nicht
auch im immobiliensektor warum
eigentlich nicht weil sie allen leuten
sozusagen sofort unterstellen dass jeder
der transparenz hat einer ist der etwas
schräges im schilde führt das ist ihre
denkungsart und die ist falsch was will
ich an dieser stelle noch mal sagen also
ich will es mal mit einer anderen
formulierung formulieren es muss ein
ruck durch die immobilienwirtschaft
durch den immobiliensektor auch die
staatlichen stellen gehen um aktuell
oligarch in das handwerk zu legen aber
eben nicht nur dafür wir haben auch eine
ganze reihe anderer maßnahmen die wir
deswegen fortführen weil das zentrale
immobilien register kann kann das muss
ich leider sagen das ist auch nicht so
von heute auf morgen gemacht es ist ein
eminenter bürokratische aufwand ist ja
eine eminente herausforderung die
aktuell sozusagen nicht zu bewältigen
ist das ganze wird erhebliche zeit in
anspruch nehmen um so lange sollten wir
weitermachen bei anderen fragen bei der
verfügbarkeit von grundstücken durch
waren besseres vorkaufsrecht
beispielsweise durch eine bessere
bodenpolitik durch steuerehrlichkeit
scheer die uns beispielsweise und
ähnliche dinge mehr und natürlich auch
bei der bekämpfung der geldwäsche ich
glaube das werden ganz spannende
beratungen und herzlichen dank
so weit der sprecher für kommunalpolitik
bernhard teil druck hat hier schon mal
die beratung angesprochen die folgen
mehrere ausschüsse werden sich damit
beschäftigen
welche ausschuss die federführung
übernimmt ist noch unstrittig das wird
dann hier auch gleich abgestimmt aber
vorher haben wir noch eine rednerin das
ist sabine kurtz macher von bündnis
90/die grünen und sie sitzt im
finanzausschuss
[Applaus]
sehr geehrte frau präsidentin sehr
geehrte kolleginnen und kollegen wenn
die hermine darstellerin emma watson
eine immobilie in großbritannien über
die lyrisch klingende briefkastenfirma
falling leafs kauft um aus
datenschutzrechtlichen gründen ihre
identität zu verschleiern da kann man
sich fragen ob das vielleicht noch
magische steuer tritt sind wenn aber
sanktionen gegen oligarchen nicht
durchgesetzt werden können weil
eigentumsverhältnisse im
immobilienbereich nicht transparent
vorliegen dann zeigt die realität
deutlich die baustellen um die
schlupflöcher
doch auch unabhängig von den
sanktionslisten muss die bekämpfung von
geldwäsche im immobilienbereich gestoppt
werden da sind wir uns einig und ich
schließe mich persönlich dem transparenz
fanclub da auch wirklich gerne an
in der vergangenheit wurde auch durch
aktive oppositionsarbeit einiges
erreicht ein grüner antrag war 2009 10
zb anstoß für eine gesetzesänderung dank
der seit 2000 20 ausländische
käuferinnen und käufer bei der
grundbucheintragung namen und adresse
für das transparenz register angeben
müssen ein erfolg und auch die eu will
in der sechsten geldwäscherichtlinie
hier nachziehen und dem deutschen
vorbild folgen
ist das ausreichend
natürlich noch nicht denn geldwäsche im
immobiliensektor verschwindet nicht von
zauberhand sondern muss aktiv bekämpft
werden die geplante datenschutzkonforme
verknüpfung eines datenbank grundbuchs
mit dem transparenz register wird der
verschleierung der wahren eigentümer und
eigentümerin hier endgültig die
tarnkappe nehmen wir setzen uns außerdem
für eine unabhängige eu geldwäsche
behörde mit sitz in frankfurt am main
ein war hiervon profitiert auch der
kampf gegen geldwäsche zum beispiel ich
missbrauch von krupp das ist
wunderbar
idealerweise wird die bekämpfung von
geldwäsche aber schon im vorfeld
verhindert zb durch das verbot des
erwerbs von immobilien mit bargeld ein
wirklich wichtiger punkt und die
verpflichtende ladungsfähige anschrift
veränderungen und gut denn geldwäsche im
immobilienbereich kostet den staat nicht
nur milliarden sie ist ein preistreiber
das sehen wir hier in berlin dass ihnen
aber auch im ländlichen raum gesicht
auch bei mir im oberbergischen kreis zum
beispiel
und gut abgestimmte maßnahmen zur
bekämpfung sind notwendig und mit
unseren daten sparsam modell der
verknüpfung von datenbank grundbuch mit
dem transparenz register und technisch
guten recherchemöglichkeiten vermeiden
mit doppelstrukturen und verbinden
datenschutz mit effektiver
geldwäschebekämpfung denn nicht viel
hilft viel sondern die wichtigen daten
helfen viel und wir freuen uns auf die
weiteren konstruktiven beratungen und
stimmen der überweisung zu vielen dank
für ihre aufmerksamkeit
da besteht sich die aussprache zu diesen
punkt und wir kommen so der überweisung
interfraktionell wird vorgeschlagen die
drucksache auch die drucksache 15 13 an
die ausschusssitze überweisen die sie in
der tagesordnung finden damit sind alle
einverstanden aber die federführung ist
strittig die fraktionen von spd bündnis
90/die grünen und fdp wünschen
federführung beim rechtsausschuss die
fraktion die linke wünscht federführung
beim finanzausschuss ich lasse zunächst
abstimmung über den überweisungs
vorschlag der fraktion die linke wer
stimmt für diesen überweisungs vorstand
das sind die fraktion die linke und die
cdu csu fraktion der stimmt dagegen
das sind die koalitionsfraktionen und
die afg möchte sich jemand enthalten
das sehe ich nicht dann ist diese
überweisungs vorschlag abgelehnt wir
kommen zum überweisungs vorschlag der
fraktionen von spd bündnis 90/die grünen
und fdp federführung im rechtsausschuss
wäre es dafür
vielen dank wir es dagegen
sie sind wahrscheinlich dagegen
enthält sich jemand das ist nicht der
fall dann ist diese überweisungs
vorschlag angenommen bei zustimmung
durch die koalitionsfraktionen und die
afd die einen bringen und die linke und
die cdu csu fraktion waren dagegen
niemand hat sich enthalten herzlichen
dank dafür ich rufe jetzt auf den
zusatzpunkt nummer 9
anspruch gemäß § 39 der geschäftsordnung
der abgeordneten beatrix von storch
gegen einen in der letzten sitzung
erteilten ordnungsruf der einspruch
wurde als unterrichtung verteilt der
bundestag hat über den einspruch ohne
aussprache zu entscheiden und wir kommen
gleich zur abstimmung wer stimmt für den
einspruch
wer stimmt dagegen
enthält sich jemand das ist nicht der
fall herzlich dankt damit ist der
einspruch bei
pro-stimmen durch die afg fraktion und
allen anderen im haus zurückgewiesen
wir kommen so und hier nochmal zur
erläuterung es gab ein ordnungsruf von
der bundestags vizepräsidentin petra
bauer gegenwehr tricks von storch weil
sie fotografiert hatte hier im
plenarsaal das foto wurde zwar nicht
veröffentlicht aber petra pau hat diesen
ordnungsruf aufrechterhalten weil es
hier ein fotografierverbot gibt und
dagegen hat hier die afg einspruch
erhoben dass dieser ordnungsruf ihrer
meinung nach nicht gerechtfertigt ist
und deswegen haben die abgeordneten
jetzt noch mal abgestimmt also diesem
anspruch nicht zugestimmt der
ordnungsruf bleibt also damit bestehen